hillarie 2.0 that's the focus of
tonight's angle part 1 something very
odd is happening in the Democratic Party
and it's beyond the usual jockeying for
pole position by the candidates
desperate to remain viable it's more
than that the funny thing is the
so-called experts even Obama reportedly
keep telling people that Biden shouldn't
be the Democrat nominee we're now
sitting here with the Democratic
frontrunner having a spokesperson trying
to defend his comments on bussing when
you're trying to hide the candidate that
probably means you don't have a good
candidate that's like weekend at
Bernie's where the guy was dead and
there were tend like he was alive
President Obama reportedly told Joe
Biden directly quote you don't have to
do this Joe you really don't wouldn't
you love to be in the room when that
conversation happened but despite some
shaky debate performances and more than
a few medical alert moments Biden has
gained 7 points on his rivals since June
you could call this medicare advantage
he now has a double-digit lead over his
2020 rivals but there are reasons for
concern the closer you look at Biden the
more it all comes into focus
doesn't this begin to feel like the
Hillary campaign the frailty the
flip-flops the conflicts abroad and of
course the messy family life
Biden's campaign it's looking like a bad
sequel Hillary 2.0 and the warning signs
are all there just look at both of the
candidates their overall fitness for
office Hillary's campaign spent a lot of
time fighting off concerns about the
former First Lady's health for her it
was questions surrounding her physical
condition new questions this morning
surrounding Hillary Clinton's health the
Democratic nominee now forced to cancel
campaign events in California after she
collapsed at the nine
11 memorial boy they shoved her into
that Scooby van fast didn't they after
the fall Hillary's doctor scrambled to
reassure voters my overall impression is
that mrs. Clinton has remained healthy
she continues to remain healthy and fit
to serve as president of the United
States well at 76 Biden's even older
than the former first lady but for him
the concerns are about his mental or
cognitive fitness Politico attempted the
journalistic equivalent of a medevac
mission by locating the brain surgeon
who operated on Biden back in 1988 who
claimed that Biden is quote every bit as
sharp as he was 31 years ago I haven't
seen any change which led many to wonder
you mean Biden's been like this for
decades country wasn't built by Wall
Street bankers CEOs and hutch next one
many union workers the UAW took
incredible cuts in their future and
their pensions and the left to get GM
working investing much more in medical
research to comfort to conquer
devastating diseases like cancer
addiction and Alzheimer's but don't
worry
remember the surgeon said he's as sharp
as he was 31 years ago well Biden like
Hillary is willing to jettison his
long-held political positions to try to
win over the radical elements of his
party on trade for example Hillary
supported the trans-pacific partnership
the TPP while in Obama's cabinet I did
say when I was Secretary of State three
years ago that I hoped it would be the
gold standard it was just finally
negotiated last week and in looking at
it it didn't meet my standards my
standards for more new good jobs for
Americans for raising wages for
Americans and I want to make sure that I
can look into the eyes of any
middle-class American and say this will
help raise your wages and I concluded I
could not mister flip meet mrs. flop
same story of course but NAFTA
which by the way was signed by her
husband everybody is in favor of free
and fair trade and I think that NAFTA is
proving its worth I said I would like to
renegotiate it when I ran back in 2008
no no that's for Biden back in the olden
days of 2015 his office said he quote
supports the TPP agreement and will help
pass it on the hill but here's Biden
last month I would not rejoin the TTP as
it was initially put forward I would
insist that we renegotiate pieces of
that way did he say TTP we forgot that
in our gaffe montage oh my god you see
his ancient position of four years ago
was the establishment Democrat position
it was Pro free trade and pro
globalization no questions asked but
that's not where the energy of his party
is today Biden like Hillary is trying to
placate the socialists and the ranks of
the party to blunt the candidacies of
Warren and Sanders that's why they do
that and then there are the messy Family
Matters Hillary had bills CD reputation
in the anvil of the Clinton Foundation
around her neck that was a personal
slush fund financed by oligarchs who
wanted guaranteed access to the next
president as for Joe Biden he has a son
Hunter the lucrative business deals in
the Ukraine in hunters Chinese business
Till's which the former VP helped
facilitate
during his official travel and that's
part one of the angle